be silent
or let thy words be worth more than
silence
no one is free who has not obtained the
empire of himself
no man is free who cannot command
himself
educate the children
and it won't be necessary to punish the
men
do not say a little in many words
but a great deal in a few
rest satisfied with doing well
and leave others to talk of you as they
please
in anger we should refrain both from
speech and action
don't judge your greatness by your
shadow at sunset
[Music]
the oldest
shortest words
yes
and no
are those which require the most thought
a man is never as big
as when he is on his knees to help a
child
let no one persuade you by word or deed
to do or say whatever is not best for
you
silence is better than unmeaning words
do not chase after happiness
it is always in you
whatever they think of you
do what you think is fair
be equally indifferent to blame and
praise
do not look back when leaving
choose rather to be strong of soul
than strong of body
above all things
respect yourself
reason
is immortal
all else
mortal
salt is born of the purest parents
the sun
and the sea
number
rules the universe
declining from the public ways
walking in unfrequented paths
friends share all things
as soon as laws are necessary for men
they are no longer fit for freedom
choose always the way that seems the
best
however rough it may be
custom will soon render it easy and
agreeable
anger begins in folly
and ends in repentance
a blow from your friend
is better than a kiss from your enemy
practice justice in word indeed
and do not get in the habit of acting
thoughtlessly about anything
never trust a friend who speaks bad of
his comrades
you should make great things
not promising great things
it is difficult to walk at one in the
same time many paths of life
power is the near neighbor of necessity
as soon as you awake
in order lay the actions to be done the
coming day
ability and necessity dwell near each
other
time is the soul of the world
be a good son
just brother
spouse tender and good father
even as truth does error have its lovers
above the cloud with its shadow is the
star with its light
above all things reverence themselves
a fool is known by his speech
and a wise man by silence
[Music]
wisdom thoroughly learned will never be
forgotten
don't try to cover your mistakes with
false words
rather
correct your mistakes with examination
[Music]
sobriety is the strength of the soul
for it preserves its reason unclouded by
passion
concern should drive us into action
and not into depression
friends are the companions on a journey
who are to aid each other to persevere
on the road to a happier life
most men and women
by birth or nature
lack the means to advance in wealth and
power
but all have the ability to advance in
knowledge
learn silence
with the quiet serenity of a meditative
mind
listen
absorb
transcribe and transform
the great science of living happily
is to live only in the present
if you can become an eagle
do not strive to become the first among
the jackdaws
a person who is captured by his passions
cannot be free
[Music]
if you cannot have a faithful friend
be your own friend
drunkenness is an exercise in madness
he who sows the seeds of murder and pain
will not reap joy and love
legislation should be the voice of
reason
and the judge should be the voice of the
law
we hope for your support in the form of
likes and comments
thank you for watching